welcome back to new rock stars this is
the big question the show that gives you
too much information about what evil
dimensions that magician at your fifth
birthday party was tapping into when he
pulled that rabbit out of the hat oh god
probably the sixth dimension
that's where all the rabbits come from
my name is unt and i'm here today with
off-screen producer
brandon what's going on brandon oh not
much you know just really betraying my
title of off-screen producer sorry i
keep sneaking in here
you are now screen producer brad i know
i'm getting worried they're going to
take my title away hit me with that big
question brandon okay
it's finally got its release in theaters
it's finally here it's wonderful it's
beautiful but now we've been introduced
to what seems like a completely new form
of magic in the mcu like a whole nother
form of magic pokemon gotta collect all
this magic and you know frankly that
leads us to this week's big question
what are all the different forms of
magic that we have seen in the mcu hmm
that is a really great question like
because yeah shane she brings up a very
new type of magic that we've never seen
before it's brand new and like no one no
one bothers to explain it to us yes it's
like sort of like airbending in this
weird like avatar the last airbender
type of way water but yes
earth
fire
air
that is a great question brandon but
before we get into it we should have
mentioned that we will be covering some
new concepts introduced in the latest
mcu film chongqi and the legend of the
ten rings and we're going to try and be
somewhat broad about it but if you're
worried about spoilers at all consider
this your warning this is the spoiler
warning if you haven't seen chongqi what
are you doing kung fu waits for no one
let's talk magic in the mcu it's more
than just different and pretty colors
okay we'll start with some of the first
magic we were first introduced to in the
mcu and that would be asgardian magic ah
yes and this is the type of magic we
were first introduced to in thor and we
all recall ford described the mythical
nature of asgard and its people as a
combination of both science and magic
and asgardian magic is used throughout
asgard as a way to power vehicles
weapons and even medical devices like
defibrillators just kidding that's just
here
oh that it's true
it's a magic different defibrillator i
can't say it defibrillator
i think that defibrillates yeah i've
never heard defibrillate used as a verb
that way defibrillate that man doctor
defibrillate that man we're not saying
it right we are not saying it right we
saw in thor the dark world how the magic
powered machine was used to help jane
foster who was pumped full of that red
goo that red glue that was sucking all
of her light force i was taking it away
yeah that machine was really cool it was
like magic and like it's very mystical
but scientific these guardians have a
very long lifespan and they spend a lot
of that time studying asgardian magic to
see how it can best be used to improve
their lives like items can also be
imbued with asgardian magic as well
including some of the enchanted items in
odin's vault and asgardian magic can
also be wielded by the citizens of
asgard and even by orphaned frost giant
runs like a certain loki and though loki
tends to use it for more nefarious
purposes as loki's do but we do see them
do all sorts of things with asgardian
magic including mind control illusion
and manipulation on my way down to
coordinate search and rescue on my way
down to coordinate search and rescue
telekinesis clairvoyance and conjuration
it's all part of their lives they love
the magic and asgardian magic also
provides the power for the odin force
the magical force wielded by the leader
of asgard who named it after himself
apparently well there were like other
leaders of asgard before oh dude it
wasn't called the bore force right
force that'd be so like oh i'm so boring
out here he's bored talking against the
boar
no
do you think boar was like boris like
i'm using the odin force and they're
like why is it called the odin force
he's like you'll see
the sun
i'm gonna have a son it'll make sense
later
leave me alone i'm tired the odin force
is directly connected to the wielder the
olden force can be used to imbue objects
with power for example mjolnir our
favorite magical object in the mcu what
is the name of thor's hammer magogner
jonathan who i feel i mean other than dr
strange's cape it can also be used to
generate the odin sleep which heals and
replenishes the power of the user unlike
you know my uh my my naps which make me
more time more time i don't know how
that happens
um but that's just that's the mt sleep
the odin force is like a part of
asgardian magic but only one person can
really do it in it you gotta be you
gotta be the king or queen to do it i i
hope they rename it to the valkyrie
force because
i wonder if she has it
crazy we better see oh my god that i
can't i hope she has it she's better
users of asgardian magic can also use it
to channel dark energy and odin and
heimball both do this when they need to
teleport people across the galaxy
without the aid of the by fraud
in fact heimdall is a powerful wielder
of asgardian magic and this is how he's
able to keep an eye on someone no matter
where they are in the universe like
pretty much everyone in the universe i'm
dolphins either i'm dolls watching i'm
watching you
always watching yeah heimdall and uwatu
are the biggest perverts in the marvel
multiverse
loki is able to hide from heimdall right
like he's a he's so good with that
guardian magic that he can like kind of
hide himself because the heimdall's like
i couldn't see what you were doing can
you tell me where loki is hiding
i'm in hiding you can't see me because
of loki
no it's it's so true and like it's it's
so weird how like there's certain things
that heimdall can't see like when when
jane foster disappeared and when she
when she first came in contact with the
ether he's like i don't know where she
went where'd she go i hope they sort of
go into why heimdall can do this because
we don't know much about heimdall's past
it'd be cool to like see like heimdall
growing up and be like oh you saved
someone from an accident and chemicals
fell on your eye now you can see
everything and this other guy he's blind
young heimdall this fall on disney plus
i know and matt murdock have the same
origin story but one of them lucked out
and as guardian magic does not appear to
require any spells or incantations which
is pretty freaking sweet i gotta say i
feel like dr strange would have loved
that when he was trying to you know make
spells with his broken hands it also
does not require any user to wield any
objects to manipulate the magic however
as we stated earlier objects can be
imbued with asgardian magic so that's
asgard that's all the asgard that does
make sense i like what you said empty
about them like living so long and just
studying it like they're so they have so
much time to get good at the magic yeah
they don't have to be doing all that
what is it ten thousand hours yeah yeah
right it makes him an expert
anyway let's talk about eldritch magic
next this type of magic is most famously
wielded by dr strange you know the
ancient one and the other masters of the
mystic arts practitioners of eldritch
magic study spells and conjure eldritch
magic energy through their fancy hand
movements and it often manifests itself
in fun geometric patterns and can be
used to manifest shields and weapons
alike eldritch magic can also be used to
imbue objects with powers to create
relics especially when magic is too
strong for one person to wield and the
sling ring is a perfect example of this
and we've seen these magical relics in
the mcu like you know mordo's staff of
the living tribunal and the vaulting
boots of valtor like that scene is
perfect
i wanted like 50 more relics i was like
just show me the relic right maybe
let's go in the closet yeah but stop
training it's going to drag me in the
closet show me everything i want the
cloak of invisibility please yeah that
seems pretty cool there's also of course
wong's wand of what tomb and doctor
strange bloke of levitation i feel like
dr strange's cloak deserves full
avengers status because he helped he
helped that cloak does the work it's
doing the work he he kept thanos his
hand closed like he's literally an
avenger he gives me hardcore carpet from
aladdin oh yeah oh yeah
like i love i i hope that there's an
aladdin variant that's like a sorcerer
supreme and he wears the the carpet as a
cave that'd be hilarious i like that but
there are a ton of spells that we have
seen in the mcu that fall under eldred's
magic including illusions conjurations
duplications energy blasts and even that
bad earth swallowing spell doctor
strange pulls off during the final
battle in endgame because he's a boss
like that man knows too many magical
spells i love it teach me
speaking of end game eldritch magic is
also able to manipulate the infinity
stones dr strange is able to use the
eldritch to magic spells that he learn
in the library of commertage to engage
the time stone so long as it is housed
in its magical relic known as the eye of
agamotto that's really interesting empty
i didn't think about that they used
their their eldris magic spells on an
infinity stone but this probably is
because it's in the eye of agamotto
right like if it was just sitting on the
table they might not be able to like do
that same spell it's magic science magic
science what it is magic science i love
magic science it's also worth noting
that eldritch magic is not specific to
earth because we also see if you
remember at the end of guardians of the
galaxy volume 2 the coolest ravager i
feel in my opinion krueger pull off a
little eldritch magic of his own at the
end of that movie and i i cannot wait to
see more interstellar magic because
that's a whole like they opened up a
whole can of work i want to see doctor
strange in space it's like there's this
whole arc in the comics where uh doctor
strange goes to space let's just do that
doctor storage three space adventure
like grab some guardians just go to
space but if you have the light then you
must also have the dark so let's take a
look at two different types of dark
magic that we have seen so far in the
mcu starting with of course we gotta
talk about it the big ass head in the
weird world a dormammu in the dark
dimension magic from the doctor
mentioned the home of our you know good
buddy dormammu is channeled by both the
ancient one and casilius in the mcu so
far we don't know what else has it uh
because like i've always said once you
go black it's hard to go back brandon
you always say that and the magical
power provided by the dark dimension
appears to be specifically tied to
extending one's lifespan as well as
increasing their physical strength and
you can also get a sick forehead tattoo
and sometimes some magical
conjunctivitis yeah it really messes up
their eyes i don't know why i didn't
mess up the ancient one's eyes i guess
she figured out a way to like hide that
because like like she hid the the little
tattoo you know how border always says
the bill is always due maybe she
sacrificed her hair oh
good trade good trade-off good training
no one knew
i don't know if that's a good trade-off
i do miss my hair the bill comes due and
when drawing power from the dark
dimension to extend her life the ancient
one appears to still be performing
eldrit's magic so that means it's not a
one of the other type of thing but
rather the two forms of magic can be
used in conjunction you know sort of
simultaneously because for the most part
both her and kaiselius are still doing
like eldrish magic when they're fighting
each other it's just like the dark
dimension magic she's giving that extra
boost to power and we find out in doctor
strange one that dark dimension magic
works even better in the mirror
dimension so that's a weird little perk
of dark dimension magic there their
connection to the dark dimension makes
them more powerful in the mirror
dimension they can't affect the real
world but they can still kill us they're
already powered up in the power-up place
so they're powered up to powered up
double powered up double powered up the
other form of dark magic that we need to
discuss is something that we're going to
call dark magic and this is the magic
that makes a lot of sense empty that
makes a lot of sense
we're going to call this dark magic
ernest hemingway that's me this is the
magic performed by our favorite lovely
hbic
the hw ic the head witch in charge
agatha harkness that we saw in the wanda
vision and it's possible that this is
another form of eldritch magic but it is
interesting to note that when agatha was
being kicked out of her coven she was
accused of practicing and i quote the
darkest of magic the darkest magic and
agatha has been alive for quite some
time and her ability to absorb the
magical abilities of her sisters shows
her adeptness at dark magic and plus she
has had plenty of time to hone her
abilities through the studying of the
darkhold the most evil book that you can
check out at the library if you check
out the dark holder your public library
you're going on a list and we don't know
how long agatha has had the dark hold
for it has appeared in other marvel
series such as the runaways and agents
of shield but those aren't necessarily
canon within the mcu anymore so it's
possible that agatha has had the
darkhold for hundreds of years but she
likely didn't have it yet at the time
that she was kicked out of her cover
agatha uses runes and incantations along
with some slight hand gestures you know
because which has got to do that yeah
she seemed like really tied to having to
say spells right uh which we don't see
that as much with like the the standard
eldritch magic where they're just kind
of doing the things and making the
patterns she was like big on spells
in wanda vision that might just be her
style maybe like dark magic really
requires you to say the words say the
words say the words
shazam agatha's dark magic manifests
itself with a purple hue because purple
is the darkest of colors remember that
and very similar to the colors that we
see in the dark dimension and they're
not the same source of that magic but it
is interesting that they have the same
color huge it's not clear when agatha
came into possession of the dark hole
but it is clear that she has had some
innate dark magic abilities of some sort
yeah i think she was like doing dark
magic before she got that dark cold and
then when she got it she was like really
into it hey man it's just it's addicting
stuff very addicting good [ __ ] um
it probably has a really good uh preface
the it's got pictures we know that much
it's got great pictures yes but anyway
the next form of magic we're going to
dive into is a magic only seen wielded
by one person in the mcu and that person
has got to be the baddest magic wielder
of them all the scarlet witch oh yeah
and the magic power is called the chaos
magic chaos magic is very rare and
extremely powerful within the mcu and
we've seen its ability to alter reality
on a massive scale as it turned the
entire town of west view and its
residents into the playthings of wanda
maximoff and the people outside of
westview didn't even know what lester
you even existed they were like what oh
east view where from east view where
these few cops yeah she did all that
without like knowing how to do it and
that's how powerful she was and that's
how powerful the magic is right agatha
was just dumbfounded she's like how did
you do it like tell me you're clearly a
witch how did you do this is the
craziest smell i've ever seen you gotta
tell me how she's just like i don't even
know i just got it like that yeah i was
just born this way maybe it's a
maybelline i don't know i'm built
different
the dark hole warned the power of the
scarlet witch which is why agatha was so
eager to steal her power chaos magic is
potentially the most powerful magic that
we've seen in the mcu yet and we've only
just begun to see his potential and i'm
sure we're going to see a lot more of
what that chance magic can do in the
upcoming doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness if we don't i'll
be very disappointed because why why
would why wouldn't we that'd be very
weird and now that brings us to the
magic that we saw demonstrated in
shanghi and we're not talking about the
rings themselves because who really
knows what's going on there but instead
we're talking about the magic we see
wielded in the ancient village of tallow
by the people like shengshi his mother
and his aunt and that magic was given to
the village by the great protector for
our own purposes and since nobody in the
film bothered to give it a name we're
going to call it tallow magic because
you know that makes sense just make you
just make terminologies here which
well they're not going to bother to
identify it we will exactly update the
wiki it's title magic get the wiki
and since the great protector is a being
from another dimension it would stand to
reason that this magical ability is also
drawn from that same dimension this does
make it similar to the dark dimension
magic in some aspect not 100 yeah i
don't think it's dark magic but it is
interesting how it's like probably
coming from another dimension wielders
of tilo magic don't need to speak any
incantations to use it they seem to do
it completely through gestures almost
like they are moving the energy
surrounding them like freaking
airbenders i'm so jealous i want to be a
jealous do that
jesus christ the only thing that air
does around me is push me over my bones
are made of the same material they made
uh they make czech cereal so it's
possible that the tallow magic can be
imbued in objects such as the pendant
that shengshi and his sister wear though
we're not entirely certain if the
pendants themselves had any magical
properties as it's never really
demonstrated what's really distinct
about the tallow magic is that it
doesn't seem to manifest any color when
manipulated by its wielder so like that
seems to be a first in the mcu they ran
out of colors i guess i don't know is no
color of color but maybe that is like a
a big distinction for this type of magic
the lack of color could mean something
dramatic about it who knows maybe it's
like putting a silencer on your magic oh
yeah you can sneak up on somebody
yeah cause if like you're doing magic in
like a room you know someone outside the
window can see the lights flashing
they're like oh they're doing magic in
there but you wouldn't exactly you could
only practice magic safely at a rave you
know no one's gonna see you out of rage
because everyone has the lights
that's how
maleficent's crow found uh aurora right
exactly those witches were just being
those fairies they're just shooting
colors all over the place it's like you
gotta hide your magic come on if they
had the transparent water magic like in
shanghai now that's what happened come
on flora fauna merryweather get it
together
get it together most of my experience
with those three witches and sleeping
beauty is through the kingdom arts
series okay so like i've only watched
sleepy beauty one time oh empty
disappointed disappointed it's my
favorite oh it's your favorite it rains
supreme it's beautiful it's gorgeous i
love it wow
it's pretty good though don't add me bro
and what's really interesting here is
that tallow magic is also tied directly
to the village of tallow which once
someone leaves that village they are
unable to wield that magic anymore so
it's like a a magical wi-fi system if
you will like once you're out of range
you're no longer connected and it's the
first time we've seen a localized form
of magic in the mcu i mean it would be
great if you if you owned an airbnb in
that village because you could be like
come stay here you get magical powers uh
and it's sleep six great i wonder if
this is specific to all the humanity
within the mcu and maybe we'll get an
explanation for this in the upcoming
eternals film because you know as we
learn in the eternal film the celestials
were responsible for all for altering
our genetic code right so what if
something within our code that they
altered allowed us to be you know sort
of like receptacles for whatever you
know magic energy tallow uh allows
people to become these you know little
uh airbending you know magical type
warriors yeah and i wonder if what the
eternals are doing it will be described
as magic or if it's considered something
else entirely or if they're just using
like cosmic energy if that's different
from magic or maybe that's what magic is
uh mt i know you and i kind of talked
about this a little bit like in the
comics yeah you know magic all magic is
the same right it's all coming from the
same energy source but it's just like
the different wielders how they use it
it makes it distinct yeah i really hope
that eternals goes goes into like where
you know the magical energies of magic
and like you know
and again like you said the the energies
of the eternals come from like maybe
they're all coming from the same source
but like you know different types of the
same source like there's a lot of
explaining to do with the mcu in terms
of all the weird mystical it's like taco
bell right taco bell has
six ingredients uh on their menu and
they just put them together in different
ways
and that's how you get like you know 30
different things you can get magic the
mcu's taco bell so that is our breakdown
of all the different types of magic that
we've seen in the mcu so far and we
certainly hope to learn more about the
great protector style of magic as the
mcu grows and magic building beings play
an even larger role than ever before
because magic is here to stay ladies and
gentlemen by empty didn't we for didn't
we forget one form of magic close-up
magic
editors make a make a card appear right
there
i mean oh my god brent how did you do
how did i do it oh but that was great mt
thank you that kind of helps me
uh categorize all the magical types and
it's crazy we've seen so much especially
the further we get into the mcu and the
more it expands it seems like they're
leaning more on the magic i think we're
gonna
see much more magic as we go deeper into
this next phase they're they're very
much leaning on the magical elements of
the mcu and the more you know magic
slash cosmicky type thing so you gotta
pay attention we gotta know we gotta pay
attention i'm glad i can help
but before we continue you should check
out our most recent addition to our
latest obsession line of shirts inspired
by marvel's hawa tiff it's a very cool
design with what you and a really
stylized look and it's a limited edition
shirt so you gotta grab one quick cuz
it's not gonna be around forever and
we've also got a full line of suicide
squad merch and a spider-man no way home
inspired shirt and a bunch of other
great gear because spider-man no way
home is coming and you gotta be wearing
his swag you gotta so grab something for
new rockstarsmerch.com and it's an
awesome way to support this channel to
get some nods of approval from cool
strangers who are also part of the kang
gang and all the other gangs that i've
started ever since i've joined here
so many gags and before we continue to
our bite size questions next are some
words for the folks that help bring the
big question to you folks like mint
mobile after years of fine print
contracts and getting ripped off by big
wireless providers we've learned that
there's always a catch the cool thing
about mint mobile is that there isn't a
catch mobile is the first company to
sell wireless servers online only and by
cutting out retail stores there's no
crazy overhead costs that get passed
down to you in the form of mystery fees
instead mint just passes on that sweet
savings directly to you because that's
the only thing that should be passed
down savings and maybe a family
inheritance but you know i'm not in
charge of your life i'm here at new rock
stars philip switched to mint mobile
last year and he loves it he got to keep
his phone and his number and is paying a
lot less than he was from his previous
provider who he won't name but
it's not as cool as mobile let me tell
you that and for people looking for
extra savings met mobile offers premium
wireless service for just let me hear it
15 bucks a month and all plans come with
a limited talk and text with high speed
data delivered on the nation's largest
5g network and if you're not 100
satisfied mint mobile has you covered
with their seven-day money-back
guarantee so switch to mint mobile and
get premium wireless service starting at
just 15 bucks a month so to get your new
wireless plan for just 15 bucks a month
and get the plan to shipped to your door
for free go to mint mobile.com
big q that's mint mobile dot com slash
big q b i g q and cut your wireless bill
to 15 bucks a month at mintmobile.com
oh folks we all shop online don't we and
boy do we love it and we've all seen
that promo code field taunt us at
checkout but thanks to honey manually
searching for coupon codes is a thing of
the past honey is the free shopping tool
that scours the internet for promo codes
and applies the best one it finds to
your cart honey supports over 30
000 stores online all of your favorites
are there you know it you'll love it
it's honey when you're shopping online
and go to checked out the honey button
drops down and all you have to do is
click apply coupons wait a few seconds
as honey searches for coupons it can
find for that site and if honey finds a
working coupon
you'll watch the prices drop buddy
off-screen producer zack recently used
honey to save 14 on some new work
clothes because now that we have an
office again he can't wear a robe to
work anymore hr won't allow it honey has
found over 2 billion dollars in savings
for its over 17 million members if you
don't already have honey you could be
straight up missing out on some free
savings it's literally free folks i
don't know what else to tell you and it
stalls in a few seconds and by getting
it you'll be doing yourself a solid and
you'll be helping out the channel here
at new rockstars i never recommend
something i don't use and i do use honey
and it's helped me out a lot get honey
for free at joinhoney.com bigquestion
that's joinhoney.com
big question all right brandon it's time
for our bite size you ready buddy oh i'm
ready
as the children say
all right our first bite size question
is if doc ock is a normal human how the
hell does he survive punches from the
super-powered spider-man and this is
from spoon fiesta on discord and that's
a very good question thank you spoon
fiesta because i played spider-man ps4
oh man and that final battle i punched
the [ __ ] out of knock off yeah and this
man was just surviving so i have to know
how could this man survive so many of
petersburg i mean the spider-man game
you're constantly just throwing people
off of buildings and then they like they
web to the side of the building which is
like okay i guess they're alive but then
someone's got to get that dude down you
know and yeah doesn't his web like
dissipate after like an hour so you
better [ __ ] move uh yeah you got it
you got to move bro like the window
cleaner is going to be like ash
well another one as you said empty
spider-man you know he's got a ton of
abilities but one of them is like super
strength he's really strong uh
yeah and when he's not fighting like the
big bads you know he's usually dealing
with a lot of low-level street thugs
like stealing bikes and stuff like that
he could easily decapitate these guys
with one punch if he was just using all
his strength but as we all know
with great power comes very
responsibility with great power
comes great responsibility he always
used to tell me with great power
comes great responsibility with great
power
comes great responsibility
with great power comes great big booty
wait who said that i've never heard it
said before uh so peter has to be
responsible with his powers uh when he's
doling out those beat downs so he's not
killing criminals left and right because
we all know he cries like a little baby
when he kills somebody
like killed somebody get over it peter
being an old [ __ ] peter now if man man
up peter uh
you know spider-man can he could really
turn up the punch power and knock
someone out when he's dealing with an
enhanced villain and sometimes he can do
it like one punch if he needs to one
punch man
i'm tired i want to go home take that
hob goblin
it's like my aunt needs a medicine yeah
i gotta get out of here it's pizza time
let's go when it comes to a good portion
of the rogue's gallery for spider-man
they're just normal humans with no real
strength and enhancements and one of
those is certainly uh doctor octopus
himself he's not in the business of
killing criminals spider-man so he's
gonna pull his punches a lot with
villains like daca that is if he can get
close you know most of the time when
spider-man's fighting doc he has a hard
time getting past the mechanical arms
like they're too fast there's four of
them they're coming all over the place
and his spider sense is going crazy and
he can't even get in close enough to doc
ock's body to like land a blow hashtag
mechanical armpits yeah i mean you got
to deal with it sorry spider-man
this is the deal you signed up for the
job and we should also consider that in
the comics and in the raimi film uh
spider-man is aware
that dr octavius is somewhat being
controlled by the arms so that makes him
go a little easy when he's like punching
him in the face nothing helps a man with
some mental problems like punching him
in the head repeating now it is worth
noting that in the comics all the bumps
and bruises that doc has taken over the
years uh it has caught up with him he's
had to start wearing like a fully
armored bodysuit he doesn't even like
use his real arms anymore and he has
like eight arms so he's just kind of
holding in this little pod because to
him it's like his brain is the most
important part he doesn't use his
physical body anymore it's just his
brain and these metal arms and they're
gonna take over the world it always did
bother me there was dr octopus that
didn't have eight arms total i mean i
guess he's got four legs two arms yeah i
guess i don't know does he count his
other two like his normal legs as
weapons i guess i don't just get i can't
i can't deal with the math doc i would
love this if doctor octopus like killed
a version of spider-man with one of his
like just his normal life just a normal
life just kick something he's like i had
the power all along like you weren't
expecting this [ __ ]
normally gotcha one other really
important thing to know is like doctor
octopus is well aware of just how strong
spider-man is because uh in the amazing
spider-man number 700
a lot of catching up to do peter peter
and doc are in this weird freaky friday
scenario where they like swap
consciousnesses the superior spider-man
eh they're just exploring each other's
bodies exploring each other's bodies
and so like doc as spider-man is dealing
with scorpion he's trying to tell him to
like just chill the [ __ ] out like i'm
i'm doing something right now i'm doc
don't don't say anything scorpio's like
fighting him and he's like ducks like
enough and so he punches scorpion like
in the jaw which is like the only
non-armored part of his face yeah and he
punches the jaw off like he punches it
straight off and jamison's there and
he's like hell yeah spider-man this is
my kind of stuff this is what i want to
see
and like
doc as spider-man is like oh this is i'm
pretty strong this kid could have killed
me at 14.
yeah big wake-up call for for doc that
day to answer your question uh doc only
survives spider-man punches spider-man's
punches because peter lets him survive
you're on notice doc
every breath you breathe is because
peter allows it it makes a lot of sense
considering like you said you know uncle
ben's with great power comes great
responsibility so like the fact that you
know peter does pull his punches with
these villains that keep coming back
it's just like dang like i wanna
freaking kill you like norman
for killing gwen but i can't because i'm
a nice and i have these spider powers
for a reason but anyway i got another
bite size question for you brandon
how much does one iron man suit cost to
make and how much money did tony blow up
with that clean slate protocol in iron
man 3 that was just for show this is
from iaj smith 24 on discord thank you
iag smith thank you uh and yes shane
black who wrote iron man 3 had a had a
lovely ending for it uh that ultimately
was not adhered to uh in the mcu because
we like having iron man around but the
wealth of tony stark and the cost of his
suits it's always like been a hot topic
of speculation all of these
finance-based publications would always
put out a story based around this topic
like when one of the movies came out
trying to get those clicks getting that
clickbait uh so since you are asking
about iron man 3 specifically i went
back on the way back machine on the
intranet and i found an infographic from
moneysupermarket.com
they published this back in 2013 around
the release of the film it lists eight
of the suits that we clearly see in the
film and the eight of them together cost
around seven billion dollars total so
that's why that's not that's not good
change uh so that averages out if we
average it out because different suits
have different things which costs more
costs less whatever it averages out to
about 875 million dollars of suit back
in 2013. during that clean slate
protocol 33 suits are destroyed it's
basically the mark 8 through the mark 71
they they blow up
at christmas time boom so that leaves
tony with a clean slate protocol that
cost him about
28 billion
875 million dollars damn and he also
lost his house so he took a he took a
big big head like his big hit on the
taxes
to be fair i think tony using like stark
industries to build the suits that he
personally
owns the company and i think this is
embezzling somehow
to be like oh i gotta make another
ironman suit so cut me a check for 875
million dollars and then i will make the
suit at my own company like come on dude
rich people stay rich by being thrifty
now it is time for my favorite part of
the show brandon it's the box subscriber
scraps boxes
box of scraps brandon our boxers
question of the day is what type of
magical powers from any fandom would you
like to wield and why i don't go first
for this one because i
have always wanted to have the force
powers from star wars
just to be a a force wizard in the star
wars universe is being one with the
universe and like i don't know just like
it's sort of just like obviously you
could you push things telekinesis and
like you know have like prophecies and
all that cool stuff but like just being
able to be one with the universe i just
feel like that just be really peaceful
would you stay on the light side mt or
would you no no no no um i
enjoy sex
um so i couldn't go to uh bible school
for my entire have you ever heard the
tale of darth plagueis
[Laughter]
darth plague is the wise for me i mean
this is gonna be a basic ass answer
empty but not ashamed of it you know
give me that harry potter magic baby
yo it's pretty great guardian
i think they were they did give you that
straight up like there's a lot of school
work you gotta do you gotta learn this
magic you gotta read a lot of books you
gotta do all this stuff you gotta stay
hidden from the muggles
give me the want
give me the powers give me the robe
i wanna be decked out i wanna be out
there changing into animals uh i wanna
be you know just transporting myself all
over the place
give me give me that harry potter magic
baby but you said give me the one i just
pictured you just like walking into
hogwarts first year just like kicking
the door down give me the lawn give me
the wand bro give me the one i don't
wanna i don't want these school lessons
just give me the one i'll learn it
myself yeah don't give me the lesson
just give me the wand all right
i'll do that online learning that's what
i would that's what i need
right online close magic close-up
university or whatever it's called like
he'll teach you all about the phoenix
university for magic baby exactly it's
the best one it's literally the phoenix
because
dumbledore it's pretty funny that's the
order of the phoenix university there
you go
well that is it for this episode of big
question i want to thank off-screen now
on-screen producer brandon for joining
me on the show please follow him at
grindenberric on twitter if you want to
see him be amazing online please follow
me at mastertainment but most
importantly follow new rockstars
especially at new rockstars that our new
rockstars handle on twitter and but if
you're doing it on youtube make sure to
hit that notification bell so you can
get notifications whenever we upload a
video because we do that all day every
day but yes please make sure to follow
us on twitter because tyler is a
social media maestro please
leave them some love because we all love
tyler thank you guys so much for
watching this video go to new
rockstarsmerch.com to buy some cool
shirts and we will see you guys next
time goodbye bye bye
[Music]
magic magic
you